[音楽]
は皆さんに考えて頂きたいことがあります
皆さんにとって何ヴィンターどのような1つでしょうか
並にどのようなイメージを持ちますか
文章から逃れてきた人命を狙われる2型のある人
中東や尻穴民といったようなキーワード
もしくは何も意見がない何もイメージが湧かないという方もいらっしゃるかもしれませ
ん
超私がお話ししたいのはそんなん
難民に関するものです
でも難民問題を解決するためにどうするとかこうすべきということをお話ししたいわけ
ではありません
私の愛する友人たちが私に教えてくれたことを皆さんにお話ししたいと思います
ここで簡単に私の自己紹介をさせていただきます
私は現在千葉大学の学生であり昨年の夏から1年間フィンランドで
なみー ca のボランティアに携わっていました
今日私の話に登場する友人はそこで出会った
アフガニスタン人やイラク地の人たちです
彼らはさまざまな理由で組を逃れなければならなかった難民と呼ばれる人たちでした
信ずる彼らと出会ったのは約2年前です
私が初めてピンなどに2週間のボランティアに行った時に出会いました
彼らは二十歳前後のアフガニスタン人であり私たちの何ら変わらない
元気いっぱいですしょうもないことではラツィオとこの子達です
しかしその一方で彼らは波そういう立場でもありました
ボランティア初日ドイツから来ていたボランティアに君は南部ついてどう考えていると
聞かれました
当時ドイツには大量の難民が流入していたため彼らにとって波んじゃあ身近な存在で
ありさまざまな考えがあったのでしょう
しかしその当時の私にとって何便とはあまりにも遠い存在です
何も意見がありませんでした
改めてこの問題に無関心であったと気づかされ
情けないと思ったのと同時に今ここで彼らと出会ったのは私がこの問題に向き合うべき
時なのだと思い自分のいい難民について勉強し考えるようになりました
ボランティアの中で彼らが難民である難民とならざるを得なかった背景というものを
知りました
紛争により家族や大切な人を失った人
銃を持ち戦場で戦った人
理由を様々でしたが私の目の前にいる彼らは笑顔でいっぱいなのにさまざまな思いを
抱えているということも知りました
そして私はたった2週間のボランティアでやりきったとは思えずもっと自分にできる
ことをしたいと考えるようになりました
そして
君にしかできない君だからできる方法があるんじゃないかと
ピンなどにに友人から言われたことがきっかけで1年間大学を中学し
フィンランドに渡ることを決意しました
彼らの未来を変えることはできない
彼らの過去を変えることはできないでも未来を変えることはできる
彼らの未来の可能性を広げるためには学ぶことというのは大切だと考え
17歳以上の難民が学ぶ学校でティーチングアシスタントという仕事を任せてもらえる
ことになりました
私がご覧でをしていた学校の生徒は主にアフガニスタンから来た生徒である
他にはイラクやシリアから聞かせんと思いました
さまざまな理由で国を逃れなければならなかったひとつ私は生まれ育った環境も考え方
も全く異なるような人たちとの出会いには触れ私はたくさんのことを彼らから教えて
もらいました
私たちにとって学べることは当たり前で学校へ行っていることはこれたことだと思い
ます
でも彼らにとってそれは当たり前のことではありませんでした
家がまず救っ学校に通うことができなかった
法国以外の国に暮らしていたために学校行く権利や
機会を与えられていなかったあっ
理由は様々でしたが自分と同じ時代を生きてきた彼らがそのような状況に置かれていた
ということが信じられないという思いもありました
ボランティアを始めた頃今でも忘れられない出来事がありました
ある一人のアフガニスタンから来た生徒がわからなそうにしていた看護があったため私
はその単語をスマートフォンの翻訳機能を使って彼らの言葉に訳し
その翻訳結果を見せました
でもその生徒は首を振るばかりでした
私はもう100結果が正しくなかったのかなと思っていたら2の生徒が彼女は文字が
読めないよと言いました
私はその時彼女に対してとても申し訳ないことをしたと思うと同時に報告後を読む書く
ということができるのも育ってきた人たちを目の前にして
自分の今までの当たり前というものが崩れていきました
彼女達は言いまみんなのでフィンランド語の勉強に加えて
母国語読む書くということができるようになるための勉強を続けています
年齢を重ねてもなお新しいことに挑戦し続ける
どういうふうに学び続ける彼女たちの姿を見て私も学ぶことへの姿勢というものを考え
させられますか
日本に暮らしていれば学べることが当たり前だと感じる方も多いと思います
勉強しようと言われることさえあるかもしれません
本当は世界のどこで生まれでもどこで育っても学べることがそれだ
当たり前だと思いの世界でなければいけないと思います
でもそれが実現できていないことが現実です
だからどうか皆さんには私たちが当たり前だと思っていることがそうでない世界もある
ということを心の片隅に置いておいて欲しいと思います
ここで私の友人を紹介したいと思います
彼は約傘を描くパンや18歳の男の子です
ボランティア先の学校で出会いました
彼はやアラビア語英語
ピンなどをコーラんだ後いくつもの言語を話すことができ
いくどとなく私を貸しててくれました
しかしその中では私の春突然イラクへと送還されてしまいました
彼は将来回ロットになりたいと言い誰よりも勉強し努力を続けていました
カ国の道のりを乗り越えようやくたどり着いた先便などでの生活はたった2年
財源許可が下りず突然色気と創刊されたのです
私にとっても枯れたのは彼はつらいものでしたが
彼の悲しみやり場のない思いというのはとうてい理解できないものだと思います
彼は今どうしているだろうと思い開くに付いた彼と連絡を取りましたが彼はとても
前向きでした
いつか自分の夢を叶えるために今ここで頑張るよという彼ば
なんて強い人なんだろうと思いました
また彼は独学でもした明日英語を使って今は通訳としてイラクで働いているそうです
みんなんだと暮らすことは叶わなかったけれど
今置かれている状況で必死に頑張る夢に向かった読み続ける彼の姿は私に勇気を与え
奮い立たせてくれる存在になっています
彼のように厳しい状況に置かれている人はたくさんいます
私は鼻することに波が置かれている状況が
時に人々から夢や目標が解く
見失わせるほど厳しいものであるということも私は知りました
それでも大勢の人たちは共に助け合い共に支え合いながら前を向いて歩きつづけてい
ます
写真右手前に映る彼はアフガニスタンから着た男の子です
祖国に家族を残してくるというつらい経験もしていますが彼は現在へシリングの選手と
していくつもの国際大会で入賞するのが活躍しています
東京オリンピックで再会しよう草刈ると誓った約束をかなえる日が私はとても
待ち遠しいで月
私たちはどうでしょうかっ
自分の課題たい夢やも今日自分の努力次第で手にすることのできる可能性が高い感情で
過ごせる
夢や目標を達成するビジョンを描くことができる
それがどれだけ幸せなことなのか私は身をもって知りました
ボランティア終盤を迎えこのままなーむんというキーワードから離れてしまうのでは
なくもっと自分にできることをしたいと考えるようになりました
日本に住む大学生でもできることは何か
それはいま世界で起きていることを伝えていくこと
関心を持ってもらうことだと私は考えました
そしてピンなどから私の恩師であるここ
スバ大学国際教養学部の佐々木エルゴ先生に連絡を取り
千葉大学で学生は大学で難民関心のある学生とともに
ナミー支援ボランティアを立ち上げました
今年度私たちは見る好レイプチーズと国連 unhcr 難民映画祭
千葉大学上映会を運営企画しました
今年度私たちは国連 unhcr 難民映画祭
学校パートナー度に初めて年体さえシリアに生まれてという映画を上映しました
上映会には各外からの参加者も含め170名以上の方にお越しいただき
関連イベントを含めると総勢250名近い方と共に
難民についてし考える時間を共有することができました
イベント終了後の安全とでは初めて並みについて考えることができた
関心も続けたい
もっともっとこのようなイベントを増やして難民に関する情報を得られる機会が欲しい
といったようなお言葉を頂くことができん
少しずつ関心のはというのを広げていくことができると感じた瞬間でまいりました
そして自分の中で考えているだけでは影響を与えられない
影響の輪を広げるためには
自ら行動し自ら発信していくことをそれが何より大切であると学んだ瞬間でもありまし
た
私はこのようなボランティアを立ち上げ難民に関する情報を提供していくこと
自分が経験し感じてきたことを伝えていくことが自分にできる支援だと考えましたが
支援の形というのは様々です
実際に源氏に自演をするお金は寄付する
そして私は知ることを関心を持つことと言うのも彼ら波を支える
シェイの一第一歩になるのではないかと考えます
私の友人の多くは言いました
もっともっと私たちの国について世界の人に知ってほしい
そして私たちの国に平和が訪れるように支えてほしい
そう言っていました
関心を持った人の中から次の支援につながる行動に移していく人が1人でも増えるそれ
はやがて大きな力となり影響力を持つのではないかと考えます
私の友人が言った支えるということになるのではないかと思います
だから私は多くの人に色々な事に意識を傾けてほしい
それが誰かを何かを助けることになるかもしれないと伝えたいです
彼ら波はただかわいそうな人たちではありません
確かに彼らが置かれている状況や経験してきたものは厳しいものです
でも彼らは一人の人として自らの手で自らの力で道を切り開いていける強いかつでも
あります
私は彼らと過ごす中で私たちが持っていないような強さや優しさというものを持って
いると
いくどとなく感じできました
彼らの未来はより明るいものにより希望あふれるものにするためには世界が私たちの
ように
争いもなく平和に暮らすことのできる人々がもっともっと彼が難民に関心を持つという
ことが必要なのではないかと考えます
情報どこでも誰でも簡単に手に入れられる時代になったにも関わらず
一体今の日本人がどれだけ阿蘇がにさんやイラクといった国から大勢の人が難民となっ
て国外へ逃れてくれることを知っているでしょうか
2015年頃この海岸に打ち上げられた
シリア人の小さな男の子の写真を目にした方もいらっしゃると思います
しかしいったいどれだけの人がその後シリアというよりに関心を持ち続けたでしょうか
知り合いに住む人々住んでいた人々に感性を持ち続けたでしょうか
私は人々の関心がその瞬間で終わるのではなく
鈴部ということにつながる使う霊長することが私に与えられた使命であり私にたくさん
のことを教えてくれた友人撮影の恩返しになると考えています
今ではこのように皆さんの前でお話しさせていただくようになりましたが
少し前までの私は自分にできることなんて限られている
人を支えるとか助けるとかできないと思っていました
ん
でも皆戸に行ってボランティアとしてできたことは多くはなかったかもしれませんが
それでも多くの友人がみんな&してくれてありがとう
あなたに出会えてよかったと言ってくれました
日本に帰国し自分が経験できたことを伝えていく中であなたの話に影響を受けたと言っ
てくれる人がいました
私のような普通の大学生でも何かに関心を持ち行動してみることで誰かをはしけ
誰かを支えることにつながるんだと思えた瞬間でした
だから私はこれからも一人でも多くの人に影響を与えられるように
一人でも多くの人にナビに関心を持ち続けていただけるように活動していきます
ご静聴ありがとうございました
ます